Energize your tired, hairy face by shaving
with Caffeinated shaving cream just be careful
not to nick your face-transforming Hyperlip.
Because it’s episode 56 of LÜT.
Add some extra entropy to your existence with
the Chaos Machine. A DIY toy that lets you
explore some of the math and real world applications
of chaos theory by connecting a series of
pendulums and axels to a magnet.
If that repels you perhaps you’ll find a
silent guitar more attractive. Built to emulate
the sounds of an acoustic guitar, simply plug
in a pair of headphones to play discreetly
and quietly whenever you’d like.
For a sleek and subtle way to organize scrap
there’s the Totem Intelligent Waste System.
It takes up as much space as a typical trash
can, but is divided into different compartments.
So recycling, food waste, trash, and other
household items can be separated and stored
easily.
Ease your cold, sleepy head into the Hoodlum,
a sleeping bag designed for your dome.
Then sink your body into an Inada Dreamwave
massage chair. It offers a full body massage
with 100 air cells and heated cushions to
help relax and rejuvenate your entire frame
from your feet all the way to your HandiTaur!
the most noble of all mythological creatures.
Have the Handitaur help sculpt these blocks
of clay into erasers with the Creatibles make
your own eraser kit. Sculpt whatever you want
and bake it in the oven to turn your creation
into a functional eraser.
Raise your organization game and desert dirty
desks with your Cork Cactus. A prickly pot-plant
which acts as a pin cushion and requires no
water.
However water will be required for the Tarzan
Boat, a mobile floating water park that comes
with a slide, multiple trampolines, a rope
ladder, and can be parked at a marina.
Conquer the water and the air thanks to the
Parrot Hydrofoil drone. Which uses four propellors
on a mini drone to charge across the water
two inches above the surface.
Charge up the Luminaid Packlite Spectra using
only the sun. The lantern has LED’s that
change color, the whole thing folds up, and
features a durable solar panel on the top.
But if you’d rather use the sun to draw
something you’ll need Febo, the solar paintbrush.
Made from wood and glass it can be used to
draw with solar energy by concentrating sunlight
on a specific point.
Now that you’ve used the sun to draw turn
out the lights and watch the Sands Alive Glow.
An indoor sandbox that never dries up, comes
with different tools to shape the sand, and
glows in the dark.
Put your Dogecoin into the Sci-Fi wallet which
not only does it look awesome, but when opened
makes sci-fi sounds.
Take your sound untethered with the Air LP
Wireless Streaming Turntable. Which can connect
to bluetooth speakers making your vinyl collection
cordless and can even connect it to your phone,
which you could then place inside of the hugviea
vaguely human shaped pillow that makes talking
with your friends and family on the phone
more comforting?
Comfort yourself about potential natural disasters
with the Prepper Gear Box a monthly box subscription
that sends you gear that’ll come in handy
should disaster strike.
Right. But does it come with a hotdog toaster?
Be careful you don’t eat too many hotdogs
or you’ll end up just like Barfin Barney
the Desktop Gnome. Honestly, Barney, it’s
ok that you threw up.
I donut carrot all.
And as always - thanks for watching.